can you name a similarity between apple
Google Nvidia Cisco and Oracle well yes
there are all multi-hundred billion
dollar Fortune 100 companies but there
were also all funded by Sequoia capital
Sequoia has also funded a Dashlane
doordash GitHub Instagram PayPal Reddit
SpaceX Square WhatsApp Yahoo YouTube
zoom and all of these other companies as
well
in fact the combined market cap of all
Sequoia Capital companies is adopting
3.38 trillion dollars and that was as of
July of 2019. since then Apple alone has
reached a market cap of 3 trillion
dollars so it's safe to say that
sequence aggregated market cap is well
over 5 trillion today even with the
stock market crash and all of those are
just a compilation of sequoia's known
Investments Sequoia has dozens of
undisclosed Investments that will likely
stay undisclosed indefinitely
considering this many would argue that
Sequoia is by far the most successful VC
firm of all time and that's not a very
controversial statement but it's not all
sunshines and rainbows while it's cool
to say that you've been involved in all
of these companies the reality is that
to get here there's way more failures in
fact 75 of all VC backed startups fail
so for every Apple they score they have
to deal with three wannabe apples who
end up consuming tens of millions each
but that's not even the worst part the
worst part is that when you're making so
many Investments it's only a matter of
time until you invest in someone who's
truly evil their most recent slip up was
none other than FTX in which they had a
total of 150 million dollars some of
their other controversial and borderline
fraudulent Investments included bar to
pay Trella and zilingo but despite the
Roaring highs and humiliating lows and
seemed like Sequoia has cracked the code
they've been operating for over 50 years
invested in 1800 companies and they've
essentially funded the entirety of a
Silicon Valley
so here's the story of Sequoia Capital
The Architects of Silicon Valley
taking a look back the story of Sequoia
Capital traces its roots back to a Stern
man named Don Valentine Don was born on
June 26 1932 in Manhattan New York
during the worst of the Great Depression
Don didn't have a very strong background
either his father was a regular old
Milkman and his mother was a homemaker
so grit and hardship was something that
he got used to very early on
he would end up attending a fort Dam
University where he majored in chemistry
before moving to Southern California in
the 1950s this was during the height of
the Cold War so the defense industry was
popping off and the Dawn would get a job
as a sales engineer at Raytheon but he
didn't really want to be here
you see Dawn lived by the ideology that
the past is wrong if you want to make
truly great Investments you have to do
something that's not part of the past to
do something entirely different
from Don's perspective the something
that was completely different was
obvious it was silicon wafers
he didn't really understand the
technical side of these gadgets but he
knew he wanted to be a part of this
industry
so he joined Fairchild semiconductor as
one of their first salesmen and ended up
becoming a star
he would basically build out their
entire sales department over the next
seven years in fact he did such a great
job that he would be offered an
executive role at one of her child's
spin-off companies National
semiconductor he would happily take the
job but it wasn't long until he started
having arguments with the superiors you
see Dawn felt that it was stupid that
they were selling boatloads of Wafers to
certain companies but not investing in
said companies he tried to convince
leadership to try their hand at
investing but the answer was always no
at first Don accepted their reluctance
but the more time that passed the more
he thought that he was missing out Dawn
started feeling that the next something
was no longer silicon Wafers but the
companies that were built on these
Wafers so don began investing his own
money into up-and-coming tech companies
which caught the attention of capital
group Capital wasn't familiar with the
tech scene or startups they were
primarily a mutual fund company but
while they didn't have expertise what
they did have was money and they wanted
Don to invest this money
with that Dawn would quit his job and it
creates a queer capital in 1972 using
three million worth of funding mostly
from Capital the term Sequoia alludes to
a local tree that's known to live in
thousands of years so he chose quite an
ambitious name but Don had to now walk
the walk fortunately for Don this wasn't
too hard as his first investment itself
would be six hundred thousand dollars
into Atari
Atari would go on to be sold for 28
million dollars to Warner just a few
years later so it was no doubt a great
investment but there was something that
made the Atari investment magnitudes
better if you know your Apple history
you probably know that Steve Jobs used
to work at Atari I think you can guess
what happened next
[Music]
Don wasn't the first person that Steve
approached the first person Steve
approached was actually the founder of
Atari Nolan Bushnell he offered a Nolan
33 of the company for 50 Grand but while
Nolan was tempted it he ended up
declining and suggested that Steve
talked to Don Don was sold almost
immediately he says that he's only met
two Visionaries throughout his entire
life the first one was Robert Noyes a
co-founder of Fairchild and later Intel
the second was Steve Jobs
and given that Don has interacted with
hundreds of Fortune 500 CEOs this is
really saying something but by the time
Steve reached out to Don they already
had operations underway and Steve had
wisened up regarding how much Apple was
really worth so Don had to invest a much
more heftier 150 000 into apple and it's
not clear how big of a stick this gave
him but that didn't really matter as he
would end up selling just two years
later for six million dollars that's
obviously a phenomenal return of 40x in
two years but Don didn't exactly want to
sell the problem was that Don's
investors needed their money back for
tax purposes so don was forced to sell
this was quite a shame as Donna
literally had the future world's largest
company in his hand but this taught Don
a valuable lesson never accept money
from non-tax exempt institutions Dawn
wasn't too disappointed though he
thought that the computer Revolution and
was just getting started and there was
plenty of opportunity left with that Don
would turn around and invest in
Electronic Arts in 1982. he would follow
this up with an investment into Oracle
in 1983. these were obviously
outstanding Investments That performed
exceptionally well but Don couldn't help
but feel that he just didn't have enough
skin in the game sure he was pretty good
at investing a few hundred thousand
dollars and making a few million or
maybe even tens of Millions
but there was no way that Sequoia would
reach the hundreds of millions or
billions if they stuck to this strategy
so Dawn started looking for companies in
which he could gain a much larger stake
this took quite some time but he
eventually found his Target Cisco in the
late 1980s Cisco was in dire need of
money they had already asked the Claire
for money but less than a year later
they needed even more money Cisco was
desperate and let's just say Don would
seize this opportunity he offered them
two and a half million dollars for 32 of
the company and looking back this was
definitely a predatory offer but Cisco
had no choice but to accept if they
wanted to survive
ironically this actually worked out
super well for Cisco as Dawn would bring
his expertise in management and sales to
Cisco which allowed them to become the
world's largest company by 2000. as for
the founders though well it didn't work
out all that great but that's a whole
other story
at the peak Cisco would reach evaluation
of
569 billion dollars so let's just say
Sequoia made a crap ton of money
Sequoia was now the world's most
well-known and the most respected VC
firm but they were just getting started
as they were turned around and invest
all of their profits from Cisco into.com
favorites
some of the last Investments that Don
personally LED at Sequoia was Nvidia in
1993 and Yahoo in 1995 but this was for
the best you see it Dawn was extremely
self-aware and he acknowledged that
modern companies were Way Beyond his
expertise he was able to somewhat keep
up as long as companies were actually
creating physical products like apple
Cisco and Nvidia
he could help with the manufacturing as
suppliers scaling and Logistics but more
and more promising companies were
starting to have no physical product
whatsoever and that this was a clear
sign to Don that it was time for him to
step down in 1996 Don would hand over
Sequoia to two of his most trusted
Executives Doug Leona and Michael Moritz
these two were nothing less than
absolute professionals they would not
only run Sequoia well but they would run
it exactly how Don had envisioned for
example in the mid-1990s The Duo started
feeling that much of the opportunity was
overseas at first they considered just
doing it themselves but then they
thought about how Dawn would approach
the situation if it wasn't his expertise
Don wouldn't do it himself and this was
the exact philosophy that Doug and
Michael would use overseas instead of
investing themselves these two would
assemble local teams in these overseas
countries specifically in China and
India and let's just say this strategy
worked out spectacularly
in China their most notable Investments
include Alibaba DJI JD Neo and of course
bite dance and here's a list of their
hundreds of investments in India but
just because Sequoia was expanding
internationally did not mean that they
were slacking at home in fact they were
catching even bigger fish back home in
1999 they would score Google and PayPal
in 2003 they would score LinkedIn in
2005 they would score kayak and YouTube
and in 2009 they would score Dropbox
which brings us to modern times over the
past 15 years the world has experienced
a mobile Revolution which has progressed
faster than anyone could have ever
imagined but somehow Sequoia managed to
stay at the Leading Edge of the mobile
Revolution as well their first notable
mobile investment was Airbnb in 2009
where it invested a total of six hundred
thousand dollars they would follow this
up with Evernote stripe Tumblr Square
WhatsApp Instagram instacart doordash
Reddit GitHub Zoom Robinhood Dashlane
figma and SpaceX just to name a few how
are they able to find so many winners
you ask well it's not rocket times
though they do invest in rocket science
as well the secret is simply that
they're constantly handing off the torch
to newer Generations First Dawn passed
on the torch to Doug and Michael who are
responsible for many of the.com and the
international hits these guys then pass
the torch to Jim goats who scored most
of their victories throughout the 2000s
and more recently it seems that the
torch has been passed on to Matt Miller
and Andrew reader who are both barely 30
years old in fact Andrew actually worked
on GitHub and Robin Hood in his 20s and
as long as Sequoia keeps embracing the
youth they won't be losing their own
youth anytime soon
nowadays there's a lot of VC firms out
there that have hit it big from Tiger
management to Andreas and Horowitz but
what sets upward Sequoia is through
longevity most of the other VC firms
have barely been around for 15 to 20
years but sakoya has been around for
over 50. and the craziest part is that
they were investing in Leading Edge
companies the entire time
they've literally had their hands in
everything from Apple in the 1970s to
SpaceX in the 2020s
unfortunately Dawn Valentine wasn't
around to see this as he passed away in
late 2019 at age 87.
but while Dawn is no longer with us
there's no question that his legacy and
impact will live on for as long as the
Sequoia tree itself were you familiar
with Sequoia Capital comment that down
below also drop a like if you hope that
your legacy lasts as long as the Sequoia
tree and of course consider checking out
our Discord Community suggest future
video ideas and to consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered
but until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one